and hey let this sink in you got CM Punk
verse that Jack I forget his name
Jackson over Overeem Curtis blaze cloud
Liga deja Esparza
that's so describe and then on the
undercard you got Rashad Evans and my
boy Joey Benavidez verse Pettis no seeum
puck said take a seat y'all that is so
crazy Mike Jackson that is that is so
crazy
oh and one verse Owen one does that piss
you off no cuz I get it because I'm not
a fight if I was a fighter I'd be
furious but not out of the game in the
entertainment I know what you're doing
sounds a wolf tickets there I see what
you're doing it's just the worst fight
of all-time UFC history skill-wise oh
yeah spice teas good he's about to fight
now Eric Spice Lee what do you guys know
about him I don't know anything about
him no I mean I probably seen him phrase
jujitsu is really he's really good a
weird body um where's he from gym
somewhere on the East Coast when he's in
LA he comes through my school Mercs
everybody really yeah does that does
that see him Punk Jackson stuff bother
you Joe are you used to it now bothers
me yeah I don't like it I don't mind him
fighting I think it's great that he's
fighting in the USA but he's testing
himself in the UFC even if they wanted
to do in the UFC have him on the the you
know the prelims put him on fs1 you know
make it you know make it a fight pass
thing I think his contract won't allow
that I think it's gonna be a
pay-per-view I would assume if you're
seeing Punk you that big of a draw maybe
he was is he still do you think how many
people are gonna buy that pay-per-view
to watch him fight I don't know that
first one yeah that first one you got
his ass what's so bad how long is the
WWE like raging or is it that's why it's
huge people are actually going it's
Jerry so just like that that raw the
Rosses which Fox has now which a lot
people I don't think they realize Fox
decided to go with the WWE instead of
the UFC they turned down the EOC and
went with WWE and now they have the raw
surge which gets like three something
million viewers every time they air
it's a built-in Adi I that's crazy I
always bet on dudes who have hairy backs
yeah their testosterone shoes you've way
higher than everyone else's Manny's
going bald snort two for two
he's got some gorilla back look
at that she has some werewolf type
but not hairy legs which is weird yeah
very strange it's not weird that's some
weird hair placement